I wouldn't have traded my dad for other
dads I wouldn't have yeah I did like
that I do feel lucky that I had a weird
dad and I had an unusual father
my mom used to say that he's not boring
you know and it makes you who you are I
mean you're from a you have a very
specific background in a very very you
know a very rare upbringing and that's a
great thing for you now right right yeah
at the time it felt painful but now I
realize wow this was all uh part of the
plan that's right
um we had that now I did admire like
that Magnum PI dad with the [ __ ] like
I mean just the hair coming up around
the bottom of the shorts yeah like the
hair was like trying to get back up to
his mustache you know it was like yeah
this hair has a plan that's right
[ __ ] dude and we had to go out there
and push this one dude Glenn his dad had
that big uh dish that DirecTV dish oh
yeah sure we had to push that [ __ ] to
get the porn so we'd have to go out
there and you'd earn it you know oh yeah
yeah yeah and we'd have to get that
Cinemax and we'd [ __ ] Put Your
Shoulder into it or you couldn't come my
father's odd guy and uh he sat me down
and he said uh I think my mother told me
you need to talk to him oh I had three
sis older sisters I was the only boy
so she said you need to talk to him
and what he told me was
he said when you have sex with a woman
you need to make her desire
you
so you enter her he just skipped all the
like how it works he just said you enter
her a little bit you touch just barely
touch her
and then you come out and you and you
withhold he was Mexican and he had a
weird sort of traditional
he'd say and then you and then you make
her beg and beg and then you go in again
and you go only a little bit and then
you just come out again and you you keep
withholding and until she can't stand it
and only then do you really penetrate
her and she'll
come like a rocket like he was just he
taught me how to make a woman come he
wasn't wrong right he wasn't wrong but I
think you need to tell a little kid some
other [ __ ] first
before you get to like how to make a
middle-aged woman come yeah yeah you
know what I mean yeah but that's what he
was like he was very narcissistic and
you know wow
it's about sex I mean did you ever I'm
asking the same question a mentor yeah
thanks for asking man my dad well my dad
was 70 when I was born so my dad was an
older guy yeah and so he um
he would always tell me he had dated
chicks grandmothers that were like in my
class and stuff like that and he would
show me like poems that he had written
and they were like on paper that was
like disintegrating like it was like it
was also he was teaching you about
romance yeah my dad was more of a
romancer that's nice so he was teaching
about romance but nothing about sex one
time I saw him he I think he had cancer
somebody was walking down the hall and
like
I thought he was going to have like he'd
had a new girlfriend and we were at her
house she had a nice house and she made
all this like beef brisket or whatever
I'd never even seen it you know blew my
[ __ ] mind yeah just what what your
were your parents married they were
married till I was seven and then they
got divorced and did he have kids before
with other women yeah
okay he had three other children okay so
he's now so now you're how old I'm maybe
at this point I was probably 12 and you
saw him somewhere and he had another
girlfriend yeah
you only ever had bologna and call it
concerts oh I'd never had brisket no of
course not I mean I was
yeah never even I never even couldn't
imagined it and then
um
I he was walking down the hall and I
thought he was going to like have sex
with us at night time and I would sleep
on their living room on the living room
couch and then he literally uh
he was sick and he defecated all over
himself and it was like one of the
scariest again craziest things that ever
happened because I remember watching him
and thinking well
my dad's going uh
like be with this lady you know and she
was like wealthy and I don't even know
why she even liked us but she did and
then he was sick you know and then I was
so afraid to try to go to help or
anything because he was like
he had cancer and he was getting real
sick I didn't know wow but it was that
anyway that story took kind of weird
term but yeah dude that's just life you
know but yeah it was like a moment where
there was just a lot of life but so uh
one interesting way you put it is you
say what she didn't know why she liked
us so you and your dad were like a unit
you were like a team like so did when he
left when your mom when your mom and him
divorce he went with Dad no I stayed
with my mom but I always felt like my
dad was just more loving yeah my mom has
like kind of like an emotional kind of
autism like she can't show you affection
kind of that's hard yeah and um a lot of
parents like that it's hard is there
yeah yeah
so it was just kind of like but she's a
hard worker and stuff but anyway it was
uh so then and I was kind of infatuated
by my dad because nothing he did he was
older so everything was awful little it
didn't make sense
um and it was kind of I think it was
more fascinating you know being around
him yeah I felt that way about my dad a
little bit because he wasn't like any of
my friend's dads he was a strange guy
who's a Mexican and um
yeah it was a bit like you European
Mexican you know there's a lot of
different kinds of Mexicans
um I lived there until I was about seven
oh nice um but uh but yeah he was weird
so I kind of like I was fascinated by
him but I he didn't show much interest
he I just remember him always looking at
his eye level like he didn't look down
at me much I just always looked up at
his face and he was looking that way
wow what is that do to you well it's uh
hard
but I feel more bad for him because he
didn't he was alone up there I didn't
think about that I do now because he's
you know very very old and in a chair
like this and he's alone no you know we
don't go see him much me and my sisters
yeah and my mom I mean when she was she
died and in her last year of life when
she was you know we were like there and
kept her in our houses and kept took
care of her until the last second she
had us all around her never alone
because she just was a a loving person
and she you know you wanted to be with
her oh wow but my dad was all [ __ ] up
in his own head and he was you know I
mean narcissism is like a it's a
sickness yeah and it's isolating and
it's very sad you know I feel bad for
him now I'm able to feel bad for him
because he was um it was painful to be
his kid you know physically and mentally
so
um but I'm past that 55 years it takes a
long time to you know were you surprised
how long it took to get past that kind
of stuff because I find it's interesting
a lot of audiences like kind of guys
that kind of like are fit still figuring
things out it's kind of like a lot of
late bloomers yeah I think and no
judgment to any of the listeners but
um yeah I think a lot of young men are
stuck in this time where it's like yeah
we're fake it's almost like you're
figuring sheer [ __ ] out your parents
[ __ ] out it's like it's almost come to
like this kind of like curve in the pipe
where it's like we gotta kind of figure
this [ __ ] out in here yeah I think
that's right and I think uh it's hard I
don't think you can rush it I don't
think I think it happens later because
something comes loose it just does it's
nothing you can figure out it's nothing
where you can go oh I mean you think
about it once in a while some and also
you spend a lot of Life avoiding it
right so like my when I was a young dad
and stuff I just pushed my dad away I
just didn't want to think about him so I
just decided he doesn't matter anymore
for years and like when I was little I
remember he was spanking me once which
is now to me a really odd thing is a
man's hand spank that [ __ ] bare ass a
little bony I can't fathom it now yeah
put pants yeah what are you doing it's
really gay and weird and upsetting yeah
but uh I remember being spanked so
[ __ ] hard like was it was like
blackout spray like I can't handle this
and I remember thinking to myself I
think I was about nine I thought the day
I get a wallet like oh that was the
magical thing the day I get a wallet
with that money in it and cards and that
set of keys the second I have that I
ain't never gonna look at this person
again in my life I'm getting away from
this guy as soon as I have those that's
all you need
so you had a lot you were really you
were it really yeah I really didn't like
being around him and my mother divorced
him when they were when I was 10 so then
I had a lot of years just with Mom where
he was around and he would ask for
attention sometimes and I didn't I
wasn't afraid of him anymore but I but
he made me uncomfortable I didn't like
being around there's a lot of good
things about my dad and I I owe him a
lot
um yeah totally you know and he hated
you he did and he also devoted a lot of
life to you know he was a Mexican and he
his our family Mexico they do okay and
they have some influence and they have
you know he had a better life there but
he moved to America it's sort of the
opposite of most immigrants that he went
from Mexico where he was pretty well
established to America where he had no
tools to survive and where he didn't get
the culture but he did it because my mom
was the strong one in the family my mom
worked really hard and she she raised us
and and supported us so uh so he he is
picking my mom instead of somebody in
Mexico and that's how I got to be in in
the land of opportunity yeah it's
interesting yeah it's interesting man
how that a lot of times it's our
a previous generation had to kind of
take an L they had to like really that's
right so you could have it you know it's
hard to imagine imagine that in your own
life I'm gonna do something shitty yeah
oh I'm gonna move to Toledo so my son
yeah [ __ ] you kid good good luck I'm
gonna do something I'm gonna go to Vegas
and just keep trying to win yeah I'd
rather sell my ass on the internet yeah
[ __ ] that take my chances but I I then I
so I went through years of like not
wanting to think about them and then I
once in a while I would check in with
him and see maybe we have something and
he'd feel the same and like I don't want
it and he didn't even seem interested
sometimes and that was shitty
um but then and my mom meanwhile took
care of him she after they divorced she
kept because he was kind of a mess and I
learned from that from watching my mom
do all the way to the end you know my
mom when she was dying she provided for
him and stuff and I learned about her
from that and I asked her about it I
because because she had no reason to be
with the guy anymore they had been
divorced since I was 10 and now you know
this was a few years ago
and she said I want to send a message to
him with she's leaving him some money
she said that he's I want to send him a
message that he's not alone in the world
now that I'm gone
somebody gives a [ __ ] about him
and because that's a that's a promise
she made him when she married him and
even though they divorced she's she's
still honored that promise even though
he didn't stay to his side or whatever
and so that helped me like I was a that
was a
that was a role model for me my mom
later in life and then after she died I
was about to say left uh after she had
left
after she left me by ceasing to breathe
that's great and some guys probably
think that yeah [ __ ] you Mom yeah I
needed you [ __ ] after she died my
sister and I who were were at her uh
Memorial we had for her and he came and
neither of us had seen him for a long
time and we were talking we were
standing in a room talking about we we
should uh
um where we gonna put him so we don't
have to be near him and then he walked
up with a cane and we were both like
[ __ ]
come here and we sat with them and then
we had this interesting affection for
him because Mom is gone she would have
wanted us to be good to him and he was
so weak
and he was so and I just felt bad for
him and I felt a tenderness for him so I
go to see him once in a while in this
place where he lives and last time I saw
him I just let I let go of everything it
just all went away and now I just feel
this tenderness I just feel so sorry
sorry for the guy
I'm all that's left all anger and guilt
all those bad feelings they burn away
with time they all burn away completely
and so I'm just left with it was I sort
of fascinated by him now I look at when
he talked he struggles to talk and I
look at his face and watch it struggle
you know and I feel I feel for him you
know anyway long answer sorry but no but
it's kind of a beautiful answer it's
about how life is you know it's like
it's funny when you go back to see like
kind of the Dragon whatever the dragon
is and the time has affected it and it's
changed yeah it's all time it's gonna I
mean for your listeners that are
struggle with it it's like you can rush
it and and it's okay if you have blocks
and stuff you'll you'll I mean you can
trust yourself a little bit you know
what I mean you'll get there you'll get
there when it's time
yeah I think uh I I have I had a lot of
like I was ashamed of my dad a lot I
think because of his age and so I think
I had for a while I had some issues with
that but even over time that kind of
went away you notice how I would kind of
like
probably look at him or I would
introduce him to people as my
grandfather just little things that it's
like
you know I start to think well I wonder
how that affected him or
um I don't know
it's interesting man I'll I'll just love
all that kind of stuff like how people
relate to one another and and especially
from our parents growing up did you wish
you were dead like other kids dads that
were like younger and stronger and more
dad like Dad like or a little bit but
then like some one dude you know his dad
like held up the ready-made with a
shotgun for pills you know so it was
like my dad just like bought a my dad
bought a Cutlass like a Delta 88
remember those cars yeah sure I remember
them well yeah and pull one up one car
yeah it was uh oh yeah well he had a
long kind of rectangular car wasn't it
well yeah some of the early ones were he
had a good LTD too for a while
yeah those were [ __ ] they just that
hood oh you you could just live on that
club it was so warm in there they're
always like four cats in there yeah sure
and they would stay in while we drove
somewhere like it was like
it was those parts floated too man they
were comfortable oh yeah I loved cars
like that oh I feel like you get yeah
six blocks and you're pregnant in that
[ __ ] yeah that was a dad car when I was
a kid but then when I was in high school
everybody would have those like kids
would have those they'd spray paint and
whatever you know with cans of spray
paint yeah yeah and they were like
badass [ __ ] cars I mean the bumper is
like this thick and it's pure steel it
was [ __ ] it was like makeup made of
iron that car oh they were so good and
three miles to the gallon my dad bought
his off a couple like brothers that
lived around the corner in our
neighborhood and so it had like these
big speakers in it right and so he would
drive and he couldn't even hear right
they had like 22s in the trunk and so he
would be listening to like Paul Harvey
and like uh whatever that is NPR or
something it was with NPR within or
maybe it's just Paul Harvey what is that
I don't even know who that is uh good
day remember that guy on the radio oh
yeah yeah okay Rush Limbaugh right oh he
lives in Russia okay wrestling about an
MPR are very different oh they are so he
would listen to Rush Limbaugh or those
guys and then it would be like uh but it
would be with bass right like so he
would just be driving around [ __ ]
listening to like insane like with a
real bottom to it it was unbelievable
and he always had like this old his car
was just stacked with just [ __ ]
because he my dad got this job like
going to like he would go to college and
sign people up for credit cards like
that guy or whatever oh
and that was one of the first place he
would take me there with him when I was
like 11 or 12 he even let me drive him
because he was [ __ ] like you know at
that point he's 82. so uh so as soon as
I was about like five maybe
6 or 70 let me drive him over there and
then I would stand on the table and like
bark at people to come over and get the
credit card thing yeah and I think maybe
that's where someone like my first
semblance of like getting on stage or
like saying stuff or whatever kind of
came from
um but yeah that kind of stuff man I
love thinking about growing up and what
happened and how it affects us now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one